ربما طبق الزيت لن يرافق الزعتر بعد الان
على المائده العربيه فازمه نقص بزيت
الزيتون قادمه على الطريق
السبب بكتيريا نشرتها حشرات بجنوب ايطاليا
قضت على 21 مليون شجره زيتون ليدق الخبراء
ناقوس الخطر وتوقعوا بان السائل الذهبي قد
يصبح اكثر ندره واغلى ثمنا البكتيريا ربما
وصلت اليها مع الات مصنع شحنت من
كوستاريكا بدات تزحف نحو ارياف باري
الغنيه ببساتين الزيتون يصل عمر معظمها
الى الف عام الكارثه الزيتونيه المرتقبه
سببها ايضا ما يحصل لدى جيرانهم الفرنسيين
والاسبان بسبب الجفاف والحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وارتفاع اسعار الوقود لتنخفض
انتاجيه زيت الزيتون الى النصف هذا العام
اذ توفر اسبانيا نحو 40% من الانتاج
العالمي فهل ولا زمن شراء الزيت بالتنكه
لنشتريه ربما بالجرام